is rotten tomatoes wrong about which are
the best
best picture oscar winners of all time
and which are the
worst we have a certified guest this
week and i cannot wait to bring him
on but first i want to say hello to
friends of the pod and my fellow
co-hosts mr mark ellis how's it going
mark
well it was good jacqueline that intro
made it feel like you're just excited to
get to the guest
and you don't really care about
interacting with me because
this week we're talking about high
falutin movies
and old mark ellis who loves 13 hours
directed by michael bay
and thinks white men can't jump is the
best movie of all time
maybe his opinion isn't as as heavily
weighted here
as it would be in other episodes is that
what you're trying to say off the bat
i'm not i'm not at all i'm definitely
saying that this person's going to bring
it but
yes more importantly um we're in my
wheelhouse
this week i'm excited because this is
literally what i sweat
and bleed every single day over at
rotten tomatoes
um it's one of the reasons why i will be
going on vacation
very shortly after the season is over
because i'm exhausted because
i saw the different background and i was
like wait a minute is she sneaking out
on me is she
is she skipping town because because i
know how hard you work and i will say
this for everybody this is
jacqueline's playoff season this is her
tax season
this is where jacqueline gets so excited
gets so sweaty about all these movies
but it also
has got to be exhausting work hitting
all those deadlines doing all those
interviews making all those projections
which are usually very accurate my mom
wins her oscar pool
based on what jacqueline coley says
every year and so if anybody does
deserve a vacation after this episode it
definitely ain't me
it's definitely not you oh i wouldn't
say that
i think you absolutely
deserve to win an oscar um so does our
guest this week
so does this entire list honestly
because
um i actually learned a little party
trick i i came up with
a like a like a a word associated way to
remember all 93 oscar winners
i am not the best at remembering it in
like an order like if you asked me for
1957 i can't do it but it's sort of like
the 50 state
song where it's like oh i can do the
list with my little fun little game but
i can't do it but the person we have
coming on can absolutely do that
but before we bring them mark why don't
you run down for us just the top 10
rankings of best pictures winner from
rottentomatoes.com
yeah and so these rankings are as of the
recording of this because the tomato
meter is subject to change occasionally
and what i want to let everybody
else also know is that these are based
on the adjusted tomato meter where
there's a certain algorithm that factors
in the amount of reviews that have come
in for a film so
say for a 1940 classic like rebecca that
did win best picture
that might be way differently than
something like the shape of water which
was released
just a few years ago because you have so
such a disparity between how many
critics
were actually reviewing it happily for
all you hitchcock fans out there
rebecca's still
in the top 10. so these are your top 10
adjusted i'm not going to give you the
adjusted score i'm just going to give
you what the certified fresh
tomato meter number is at number 10
is 1951's an american in paris
at 96 certified fresh number nine is the
shape of water from 2017
92 certified fresh number eight is
spotlights
at 97 certified fresh that of course
from 2015 we go a little bit further
back to our number seven movie which is
rebecca
a hundred percent fresh way back in 1940
we go back
up to the modern era with 2016's classic
moonlight
98 certified fresh at number five is all
about eve
an even 1950 release there 99
certified fresh number four tough to
think of three movies that are
more beloved than this is the godfather
at 1972's
97 certified fresh for that one number
three is casablanca from 1942
99 certified fresh at 98
certified fresh is our number two movie
parasite from 2019
and at number one 99 certified fresh
drumroll please it happened
one night just edging out howard the
duck for that spot
jacqueline it is gonna be fun to get
into these movies which ones do we love
which ones are a little too high up
there which other movies from
oscar wore past do we hold dear to our
hearts
excellent yes and i want to be clear so
the list that's on rottentomatoes.com is
a breakdown of the 93 best picture
winners
there's only been 93 years of oscar for
those of you that are a little curious
about that the very first year of oscar
there was actually
two winners although the general
consensus nowadays is that
wings which was awarded one of the two
prizes that year
is actually what we consider a best
picture but thank you
for pointing that out it is summer
crystal bernard's finest work
thomas hayden church working on
airplanes stephen weber
great great 90s sitcom wings no
no 1927 wings uh which was
one of the first movies that was awarded
primarily because it was such a huge
technical
achievement um but also sunrise
um a song of two humans was also from
the same year anyway
going back that's that that's just a
little oscar breakdown
um perducy lucy is also on hand with us
this week i know she's an oscar fan
favorite
right yes i love
the oscars i'm dressed like the statue
today
i just realized that you dressed up for
this and i look like i'm auditioning
for a second for a new live action
version of reading listen
your night is next week or actually this
week when the oscars
this weekend when the oscars uh air no
um i love the oscars my favorites
fall um written by the same person
robert bolt my my favorites
fall number currently number 18 and i
think number 73 on the list so
this list is wrong everybody
well you know what if there's anybody
that can help um sort of clock that for
us it's definitely one of our top
critics who is joining us here today
for the podcast mr eric cohn he's the
executive editor and chief critic
at indy wire um i really feel like that
is such a
short intro for what this man does but i
will add one little epitaph
because on top of hosting a podcast and
being all around he actually gave me my
first byline at a major trade
publication so
he's a friend of the pod in very many
ways eric
welcome to rotten tomatoes is wrong how
you doing sir hey good to be here happy
that my line worked out
seems like i know that's really
delivering on that front
yeah i love how you guys built me up
early on by
saying i'm just some sort of highfalutin
movie guy who only likes stuff
that a small subset of movie lovers like
to watch
as the rest of the world not we not we
don't put a wii in there
that was a mark okay okay so he wants to
play that role
i mean i watched the f9 trailer just
like everyone else and i thought i hope
it's good
you know but you spend most of the year
traveling around watching things from
all over the world and then you come
back and you want to tell the world
about them and most people just don't
want to pay attention
it's all about that lowest common
denominator but but the truth is i mean
look the oscars can can lift up all
kinds of fascinating movies and and
create conversations
about what we want hollywood to be i
mean when mad max crossed over and
became this oscar juggernaut
i thought that was pretty badass so i'm
always hoping to see that sort of
confluence of like
pop culture and then the really out
there stuff that is
not crossing over getting celebrated by
these award shows it's just
you know it's a it's a tricky rat race
to to get through and especially this
year which runs so much longer than
usual
i have no idea where we're heading with
all this looking at it um just from a
first glance from you
you know we got shape of water in there
it's somewhat now i think a
controversial best picture winner
we've got spotlight a surprise when it
took down you know the sort of big name
juggernaut but i'm just curious for you
eric um what do you think are we wrong
about this top
ten i personally feel it's right now
considering that frank capra is at the
top with it happen one night
but that's just my opinion like after
that i'm like we can
argue the rest but i love having that at
number one i adore that movie and screw
all comedies from that era i think it's
it's a bit odd for a ceremony that's
been around for almost a century that
this sort of quirky love story of sorts
is
is the greatest and of course it's
always this weird sort of subjective
marathon to define what that means but i
but i did find that a bit surprising to
me justice for sunrise
f.w murnau's movie is like
one of the first great illustrations of
how to tell
a grand love story through the moving
images and if you haven't seen it
it's it's i mean it was sort of the tail
end of german expressionism although
it's
not exactly that kind of movie but
myrnow was that kind of storyteller in
terms of how he
he told things and it's just a very
gorgeous
tragic drama of sorts
that uh that i i think of of all the
films on
on this overall list should be somewhere
closer to the top ten
but there there's there's nothing on
that list
of the actual top ten right now that i
would say is is bad
and and a lot of strong movies i never
thought that spotlight was quite of the
caliber
that other people thought probably
because as a working journalist i
i always find it strange when people try
to dramatize that work
like why is mark ruffalo running places
all the time like
just because he got a scoop like the
story will still be there if he takes
the subway and doesn't rush
there was something very very strange to
me about how much attention was given to
spotlight is this monumental movie when
i thought it was just a very sturdy
drama
so there's i could certainly quibble
with the list but i wouldn't say there's
anything on there that i think
you know shouldn't be part of the
[Music]
conversation
[Music]
you